Now we want to put numbers to gravitation.
Do this in 2D, which means we need to have vectors.
Let's place the earth at the origin.
The moon sits at a vector xm.
The spacecraft sits at a vector xs, and we need the distance of the spacecraft from the moon.
Let's call that dms,
and we need the distance of the spacecraft from the earth.
Let's call that des.
Now we can put both of Newton's laws together.
The mass of the space craft times its acceleration, as a vector now,
equals the force that is exerted on the spacecraft.
And this force stems from gravity.
It has two components.
One is the force that is exerted by the earth.
The other is the force exerted by the moon.
So, the force exerted by the earth would be gravitational constant times
the mass of the earth times the mass of the spacecraft divided by the distance
between them squared times a unit vector, that is, vector of length one
pointing to earth -- something like this.
And for the moon, we get the gravitational constant times the mass of the moon
times the mass of the spacecraft divided by the distance between them squared
times a unit vector pointing to the moon.
So how do we get these two vectors?
For the first one we can take minus xs --
that's a vector that takes us from the spacecraft to earth --
and divide by the length of xs, which is nothing but des.
For the second one, we can take the difference vector xm mines xs --
that's the vector that has its tail at the spacecraft
and its tip at the moon -- and we divide by the length of that vector,
which is the distance from the moon to the spacecraft.
Now, let's forget about the force.
Then we see that the mass of the spacecraft cancels.
What we need to know are the mass of the earth and the mass of the moon.